the jurgen experience we saw a dude in
albuquerque with a sword man late at
night
give me a hit damn dude
are we am i struggling that bad today no
no you're not struggling at all
you really got me is that a new one
jamie you opened up a new one no it's
the same but it has the the label on it
the other two that's how strong the [ __ ]
is it puts the label back on itself yeah
it seals every seal through it i can
already feel it all right
jesus
it was so bad
it's so bad when it's no i'm not joking
bro
i'm not joking dude
it's so sharp
right it's so sharp yes i feel like um
jamie you want some minutes nope
are you sure
what was the last time you had something
feel great well last night
come on let me little give me a little
hit i don't need it come on a little bit
from me i can fake it it'll help you
lift weights jamie i already did today i
feel like a sword just came on me
it feels insane
oh my god yeah put the lid on that
please
oh you're gonna take another one oh my
god you're an animal i like to ride the
[ __ ] dark homie
does it get better the second time
around it gets a little more manageable
oh my god
i feel like they're moving furniture in
my [ __ ] dna
yeah that is not good dude yeah you
gotta have bobby kennedy on man he's an
interesting dude how did you meet him i
met him um
just through like this i met him through
just some other friends
yeah and uh
and he just is just an interesting guy
he's just so smart he just has such and
he works with the environment you know
so his whole life has been about taking
care of the environment yeah he was an
environmental you're crying are you
emotional or just like freaking out
because of the smelling salts
i mean i can get emotional sometimes but
i think this
[Laughter]
and that thing made my heart slower
it's so rough it makes me never want to
play golf dude smoking that cigar
you